[Music]
[Music]
you may be thinking you're a bit late to
the party on this one buddy and yep damn
right I am
I've been moving house and also
exploring some opportunities towards the
advancement of my career I make no
apologies occasionally we need to do
these adult things no matter how lame
they can be okay so maybe I do need to
apologize we did move house I've just
been slack and distracted with
corrupting my son's childhood with the
guilty pleasures of my past but at the
end of the day happy wife happy life or
happy check happy dick cool whatever
works for you you know what I'm trying
to say the improvement of my family's
quality of life will always come first
it was just a real kick in the balls
this was all happening during gaming's
busiest week of the year so with this
video I want to sum up everything we
know about the division - based on the
screenshots developer blogs and streams
and of course the e3 conference there is
so much information that has come out
over the last few weeks I've tried to
group it up and summarize it into easier
to manage chunks but I've also list some
time stamps in the description first and
foremost we have a release date and as
predicted will be seeing the division -
on shelves from the 15th of March 2019
to build the scene I'll start with how
the story has brought us through to the
division - I better put on my story
voice for this part seven months have
passed since the deadly virus hit New
York City and the rest of the world
crippling the population when the virus
hit the division a unit of civilian
sleeper agents was activated as a last
line of defense
since then division agents have been
fighting relentlessly to save what
remains for the agents of the division
now higher than ever Washington DC the
most heavily protected city on earth is
at risk leaving the entire nation on the
brink of collapse
if Washington DC is lost in the nation
falls as a division agent who has been
in the field for seven months you and
your team are the last hope to stop the
fall of society after the pandemic
collapse as you arrive in Washington you
see that the civilians have banded
together in settlements to rebuild their
society but their very existence is
threatened work closely with them to
keep them safe and in turn they will
come to your aid and provide supplies
and assistance to build up your base of
operations giving a deeper meaning to
the people in the world around you as
pretty much already stated the division
2 will be based in Washington DC
we'll be getting a one to one ratio
representation of the actual city in the
original game we were fighting through
the narrow streets of Manhattan during
winter the division 2 has is placed in
an overgrown open world full of diverse
environments from flooded urban areas to
historic sites and landmarks in the
middle of summer DC is more open and
architecture ly diverse than midtown
Manhattan with a variety of unique
districts New York basically had two
areas business and residential
Washington has a lot more diversity and
about 7 distinctly different areas on
top of that you also have the situation
that Nature has taken back the city each
area plays differently and gives you a
huge variety of situations so in each
area you have to think about your
loadout and what you need to achieve
your goals at this stage the map is
already 20% bigger than the Division one
and it will continue to be expanded over
the next three already announced gear 1
DLC s one of the biggest things in the
division that had player numbers
dropping from day one was the lack of
things to do once they made it into the
in game the division 2 has been built
with an in-game first mentality further
supporting the division 1 statement of
the game only starts when you make it
into the in-game the developers have
ensured that players will always have
access to fresh unique and diverse
activities long after completing the
campaign
the division two's in-game will
introduce brand new challenges
progression systems unique twists and
surprises and eight player raids at this
stage we really don't have too much
information on raids just that they will
be replacing incursions and are designed
for an eighth player crew and cater
towards different specializations builds
and group configurations quite obviously
learnings that have taken from the
division one as they're continuously
ensuring the community that the in-game
is there and will be strong from day one
of the division to launch they're
running with the phrase the more you
play the more there is to do players
will have access to a full year of free
story driven missions map expansions and
new game features the division two is
also getting new downloadable add-on
episodes every three months that will
build onto the story and content not a
huge amount as we talked about on the
activities that will be available at
launch obviously we'll have the campaign
missions and the briefly mentioned eight
player raids even the dark zone the most
iconic piece of the division has only
been shown and a few screenshots there
has been some talk so the new co-op
activities but something of note worth
mentioning is the progression tracker
anyone from the forums or reddit can
relate to posts like I just came back
after leaving around patch one point
where do I start the Division two will
have something called the progression
tracker
it's basically an assistant that
proposes activities depending on your
progression in the game and what your
next milestone could be through this
you'll always have a clear list of
activities that you can approach at any
given time based on your progression and
skill level this should also help make
the game more accessible and less
overwhelming for returning players one
of the things that I was most concerned
about was how the developers were going
to handle the built depth and diversity
with this new installment historic and
recent events have shown that titles
like this favor the casual route often
oversimplifying the game beyond the
original concept with the division - it
looks like they've taken the office of
paths if anything more depth and
diversity seems to have been added
main stats you still have three main
stats but they're being reworked in the
division we have firearms toughness and
electronics these have been replaced
with armor health and skill power health
and skill power have been more
streamlined to make them a little easier
to calculate and understand but
essentially they're still the same as
before
armor however is a new main stat agents
now have an armor bar above their health
and before any damage can be inflicted
on their health bar the enemy first
needs to take down the armor mid kits
have been removed and replaced with the
need to repair your own plates replacing
or repairing armor plates takes time and
cannot just be done on the fly like the
old mid cuts the suspect alone hugely
changes the gameplay that we used to
firearms or DPS has been completely
removed as a main stat the developers
felt that too much emphasis has been
placed on that DPS number and how high
we can get it they stated that we were
often comparing apples to oranges and
that there were a large number of other
options that need to be taken into
consideration weapons still serve the
stats that we used to like damage rpm
and mag size but now we can see
information like accuracy stability
reload time and even a damage drop-off
chart to help you make a more educated
choice when picking your weapon for the
situation at hand specializations
signature skills have been removed
I can't say I'm too upset with this the
voice had trouble keeping them balanced
and we often end up being a little bit
too reliant on them with our builds in
the place of signature skills have
introduced specializations once you hit
level 30 you'll be able to select a
specialization these specializations
will equip you the powerful signature
weapon and a whole new progression tree
including exclusive mods that will allow
you to alter the way you play the game
and help you further modify your bulk to
your style of play at e3 we saw the
first three specializations the
survivalist with an explosive tipped
crossbow the demolitionist
rocker grenade launcher and a
sharpshooter with a 50 caliber sniper
rifle and this is just a start with
there's been hints that they're going to
be adding more as time goes on it sounds
like they're really trying to change
things up the builds
allowing players to fully invested or
class style of play also it should be
noted that after choosing a
specialization you're not stuck with
this choice you can switch between at
any time vanity if you love the division
fashion show side of things
you won't be disappointed the developers
have said they want to further increase
the options for how players can have
their own unique look and feel for the
characters being that the division 2 is
based in summer a lot more possibilities
have opened up there are even exotic
gear sets that once all are equipped
you'll be given a very distinct look and
it's not just the vanity items
there'll also be a clear evolution
between level 1 and level 30 characters
so as you're leveling up you'll be
gaining progression on your character
model 2 it should be noted that this
evolution doesn't mean that your
character is going to evolve horns or
wings or the ability to fart fire or
anything more than a look advancement
and earlier in the game when it comes to
the gear the slots are much the same as
the division 1 we still have 6 gear
slots mask chess gloves backpack
kneepads and holster and all pieces of
mod slots something that's news that
each piece now has a skin slash dye slot
so you can further customize your
appearance the biggest change to gear
that we've seen so far as the
introduction of gear brands brands is
essentially a new form of gear sets
every piece of gear has a brand
associated with it the brand is
basically the gear manufacturer the
company that it was made by the
manufacturer has an impact on what type
of stats are rolled onto the piece but
also the additional bonuses that are
added when equipping multiple pieces
from the same brand so it's specific
brands focusing on different types of
buffs you'll likely find yourself
leading to more towards certain brands
that compliment your style these steps
have been taken from the e3 demo and of
course are subject to change so what
about gear sets these aren't going
anywhere we'll still be getting gear
sets in the division too from what
they're saying it sounds like gear sets
of the next hereafter brand sets not
much information has come out on these
year as I mentioned earlier the weapons
now offer a hell of a lot more of a
when viewing them at a quick glance same
as before you can hold two main weapons
and one sidearm all of the same weapon
types to be brought back with the
addition of the new specialization
weapons though they have stated that
there are new weapons currently in
development one of the biggest things to
note so far is that weapon handling has
been reworked from the ground up I have
a feeling this will make weapons
considerably more difficult to handle
and that mods and buffs to stability
will become far more sought-after weapon
mods the weapon mod system has also been
reworked in the division one there are
clear best in slot options and the use
of mods outside of these options was few
and far between instead of finding or
buying mods you instead unlock them as
you progress through the game for
example when you unlock a certain type
of scope it's available for all weapons
it fits on so mods no longer take up
inventory space they're just an
unlockable option for your weapon mods
also don't just give you a certain buff
to a specific area anymore
they're there to modify your weapon now
not just an upgrade the idea is that
mods now can be used to tweak the weapon
to your style of play and that these
tweaks also have a negative effect
somewhere else for example if you were
wanting to improve the accuracy of your
weapon this might also reduce the
optimal range same as in the division
will have weapon and gear talents in the
division - there will be two different
types common silver buffs like 15% hit
shock damage and advanced as the name
suggests these are more advanced buffs
and they come with a requirement for
example steady nerves destroying armor
or weak points grats 50% whip
instability for 4 seconds requires no
full auto weapons are equipped the goal
was to make the talents more accessible
but also have you work your bill towards
some of the more unique bonuses on
screen are some of the examples that
were shown at e3 with and talents
written in the same way there are common
and advanced talents the only difference
being that when you have a weapon talent
on your gun you'll get an augmented
reality icon next to it that helps you
track the talent and see that it's
active here are some of the examples of
the weapon talents we've seen so far
[Music]
the way that skills work are more
release the same you can have two
equipped and there's a range of
different options
however the skills do appear to be
upgraded somewhat some require you to
target an enemy and others seem to work
better in tandem with the environment
one thing did stick out though they're
more powerful but they require a lot
more skill to use and they're more
interactive the four skills shown at e3
were drone sort of like a turret at
least stationary this can be controlled
remotely but depending on the mod you
consider as an assault drone to attack
the nearest enemy or a protective drone
to look after a specific target kim
launcher shoots various chemicals that
disperse on impact these chemicals could
be explosive vapors corrosive acids or
appearing nanobots hive small drones are
launched to cause devastating effects to
targets within an area a current control
device but also useful for taking the
weak spots of the heavy enemies seeker
mind much like what we used to from the
division but for the more powerful ones
like air burst these require manual
targeting
the gameplay has changed considerably in
the division two learnings from the
division one had the developers focusing
on the following areas time to kill
destructible armored agent armor lower
time to kill the division one always had
an issue with the bullet sponge enemies
it affected the gameplay and how we
approached each encounter in the
division two that had the goal of
speeding up the combat time to kill has
been lowered for players and also the
NPC's instead the NPC's now have better
reactions better animations and better
armor destructible armor bosses and
heavies will now have a feature called
destructible armor so rather than
shooting these enemies in the head with
a thousand rounds the goal is to take
down their armor precision will be
rewarded when targeting weak spots and
you'll literally be able to see each
piece of armor being blasted off the
enemy agent armor as mentioned earlier
agent armor has changed we now have an
armored bar that takes all the damage
before the agent health is affected meat
kits have been replaced by our mcus and
when using these new kits to replace
armor plates that have been blasted off
agents are forced to take cover
as these take a few seconds to take
effect so rather than spamming meat cuts
you require to handle things more
tactically when killed agents still go
into a down state to be revived but now
there is a cool-down period if dropped
within this period agents will
immediately be placed into the full down
state unable to be revived
civilians and enemy factions work a
little differently in the division to
civilians now have a key role in the
division - while the soldiers ran to the
bunkers the civilians have bonded
together to fight back and rebuild
society you'll encounter civilian
settlements that are under siege by
enemy factions they are low on resources
and struggling to survive work closely
with them to keep them safe and in turn
they will come to your aid and provide
supplies and assistance to build up your
base of operations giving a deeper
meaning to the people and the world
around you enemy factions unlike the
division one not all enemy factions have
the same unit types in the division -
NPCs are smarter and used more abilities
the only faction we've seen so far is
the true sons the story behind the true
sons is that they're a group of
paramilitary warlords who use the combat
expertise and firepower to overwhelm
their enemies leave by a former jtf
officer they're smart and organized
though based on the JTF and the division
one I can't see them being too much of a
challenge they'll probably spend most of
the time knocking each other out of
their menu screens and taking position
right in front of each others line of
fire on screen are the true Sun unit
types that we know so far
just a few key questions that have
competitively come up in relation to the
division to no character progression
there will be no character progression
that will carry over to the division to
the division to is a new game a new
character and no progress will carry
over through completing shield
commendations there are certain vanity
pieces that will be included on your
division to character anti-cheat
cheating particularly on PC has been a
hot topic with the division one while
they aren't ready to talk about it
they've ensured that they know it's been
a huge concern of the players and that
has been a large part of the lumens have
taken from the division 1 how they are
addressing this is yet to be revealed
but they'd like us to know that this has
been taken very seriously through the
division to know companion app
unfortunately no we aren't getting a
companion app for the division 2 they've
said it just isn't in the plans they're
focusing on the main game experience and
post-launch content in terms of
inventory management there's a ton of
improvement but for now they're putting
all of their resources and staying
focused on the game experience but this
isn't to say that a companion app isn't
coming out later on
if we compare the information shown at
e3 to the information we were given back
when that division was first showcased
in 2013 I feel like they've really taken
player feedback onboard this seems like
a much more honest reveal and if
anything I think they've held back a lot
to avoid the whole over-promised
under-deliver situation we had last time
my biggest concern was the
oversimplifying of the game to appeal to
the masses but they have more than
addressed this offering even greater
build diversity than we have now I'm
being optimistic but have been burned by
too many games over the last couple of
years to get too excited but I can say
for sure that of all of the games that
were showcased at e3 the division 2 is
the one I'm most looking forward to next
year I'll be picking up anthem too but
based on what was shown I have a feeling
that will just be another RPG like game
like destiny which concerns me because
destiny may be light on the RPG element
that everyone would agree with you hate
the game or love it that has a very
strong shooter mechanics that have been
perfected since the early days of Halo
if anthem is similar and to be compared
to destiny they're gonna have a tough
time unless they're really bringing
something completely new to the table
anyway this is probably more of a
conversation for another video so Linda
here now that I've fully moved in I hope
to be a bit more active my internet
speeds are roughly 10 times faster than
my last place so I really need to put
them to the test
thank you for watching and I'll see you
soon Cheers
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]